difficile de rester indifférent face à
ces images des participants aux régates
de potiron sur la rivière bécancour qui
tente désespérément de garder le cap
on a fait un petit test en taule le
niveau de stabilité de radis ça
ressemble à quoi
je réussisse ses surprenait malades
arrivent chaque année une trentaine de
personnes osent se mouiller ils doivent
y détester équilibrer la citrouille
avant le départ
c'est quoi le secret pour bien réussir
sa course de potirothon est en forme et
[Musique]
à voir un psy trucs bien balancée et
cela on peut admirer roche l'on a
beaucoup d'où cette année ces roms et
qui accompagnent les bantams des roches
ça veut dire le garder le ballon dans
une stricte hygiène mans se déroule en
quatre étapes pendant l'année en avril
on procède à la cérémonie de remise des
graines à la fin ou une tournée en
autobus permet aux producteurs de
visiter les installations des
participants le dernier samedi de
septembre c'est le jour de la pesée et
aux deuxièmes samedis d'octobre
si le moment des régates le ce principe
de fair use in schools and the san jose
à ce phénomène le succès de monde qui
ont dû prendre du plaisir ensemble il
s'est expliqué et quand même réussi ma
familiales seraient mises en fait
partout où il vient d'accepter une acura
rétro sur un rôle
après la course et citrouilles sont
retirés de l'eau avec l'aide de la
machinerie lourde elles serviront de
compost par la suite
quant aux participants après un
kilomètre de course aborde une
citrouille géante ils pourront clamer
haut et fort que très peu de gens ont
fait la même activité que en fin de
semaine ici jean philippe nadeau radio
canada bécancour